>>MEET THE REAL CULTIST.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
YOU HAVE TO HAND IT TO THE
ANTI-TRUMP RESISTANCE.
THEY'VE TRIED A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS TO STOP DONALD TRUMP.
WELL, DURING THE CAMPAIGN, THE
CHATTER AND CLASSES AT VARIOUS
TIMES CALLED HIM A RACIST, HE
WAS A MISOGYNIST, HE WAS STUPID,
A FRAUD IN BUSINESS, HE WASN'T
AS WELL READ AS THE OTHER
CANDIDATES.
HE ALSO DIDN'T PLAY NICE IN THE
SANDBOX.
HE WAS BRASH, BOORISH, AND AN
EGO
EG
EGOMANIAC.
AND NOW AFTER THIS IG REPORT, WE
KNOW THAT THEY WERE AGENTS BY
DAY AND ACTIVISTS BY NIGHT, WHO
WERE WORKING ON AN INSURANCE
POLICY TO STOP TRUMP FROM
WINNING THE PRESIDENCY.
AND THEN WHEN THAT DIDN'T WORK,
FIRED FBI DIRECTOR JIM COMEY
LEAKED HIS NOTES TO A PAL WHO IN
TURN LEAKED THEM TO THE PRESS,
ALL TO TRIGGER THE APPOINTMENT
OF SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER ON THAT BOGUS RUSSIA
COLLUSION THEORY.
AND NOW MORE THAN A YEAR AND $17
MILLION LATER, WHILE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S APPROVAL NUMBERS HAVE
GONE DOWN AND PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
HAVE GONE UP, THE ECONOMY IS
SOARING.
AND OF COURSE TRUMP IS ENFORCING
OUR IMMIGRATION LAWS AFTER YEARS
OF NEGLECT.
WAGES HAVE GONE UP, UNEMPLOYMENT
HAS GONE DOWN.
SO NOW THE TRUMP RESISTANCE HAVE
GOT TO TRY SOMETHING NEW.
>> IT'S NOT A GOOD PLACE FOR
ANY PARTY TO END UP WITH A
CULT-LIKE SITUATION AS IT
RELATES TO A PRESIDENT.
>> HE'S DEVOLVED INTO A CULT.
>> YOU CAN HAVE THE LAST WORD.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS ACCUSED OF
LEADING A CULT.
SO CULT IS FAIR TO YOU?
>> I THINK THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IS HEADED THAT WAY.
I THINK CULT IS A VERY STRONG
BUT A VERY GOOD WORD IN THIS
CASE.
>> OBAMA CALLED US BITTER
CRINGE  -- CLINGERS.
AN AGENT OF THE FBI USE LESS
AMBIGUOUS LANGUAGE.
THIS IS HOW AN AGENT DESCRIBED
TRUMP VOTERS THE DAY AFTER THE
2016 ELECTION.
TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE ALL POOR TO
MIDDLE CLASS UNEDUCATED POS THAT
THINK HE WILL MAGICALLY GRANT
THEM JOBS FOR DOING NOTHING.
THEY PROBABLY DIDN'T WATCH THE
DEBATES, AREN'T EDUCATED ON HIS
POLICIES AND ARE STUPIDLY
WRAPPED UP IN HIS UNMERITED
ENTHUSIASM.
LOOK, DONALD TRUMP ISN'T
PERFECT.
NONE OF US ARE.
BUT MORE AMERICANS ARE SEEING
THAT HIS NEW APPROACHES TO
GOVERNANCE ARE PAYING OFF.
AND THEY'RE SEEING PAST THE
CONSTANT SNIPING AND CRITICISM
AND THEY'RE RECOGNIZING THAT
THROUGH IT ALL, TRUMP HAS
FOCUSED ON MAKING LIFE BETTER,
SAFER, MORE PROSPEROUS FOR THE
TRUE PEOPLE.
THAT'S NOT CULTISH.
IT'S COMMON SENSE.
THE CLOSEST THING WE'VE SEEN TO
A CULT IS THE CULT OF OBAMA.
WHO CAN FORGET THESE GEMS?
>> YOU HAVE THE EQUIVALENT OF A
ROCKSTAR IN POLITICS.
>> THE FEELING MOST PEOPLE GET
WHEN THEY HERE OBAMA.
>> ALL THE HONORS THAT HAVE
COME YOUR WAY, ALL THE
PUBLICITY, WHO DOES IT MAKE YOU
THINK OF?
IS THERE A LOVED ONE?
>> HE'S PERSONABLE.
HE'S HANDSOME.
>> I DON'T THINK WE'VE EVER HAD
A PRESIDENT, SAVE LINCOLN, WHO
IS AS GREAT A SPEECH WRITER AT
THIS MAN.
>> EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS FIRST
FAMILY IS HISTORIC.
>> YOU'RE A BETTER MAN THAN ME,
SIR.
YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT US AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> I COULD WATCH THAT ALL NIGHT
LONG.
WE HAD SO MANY CLIPS, BY THE
WAY, WE COULDN'T EVEN FIT THEM
IN THE ANGLE.
SO MAYBE WE'LL DO A SPECIAL SHOW
JUST TO REVIEW ALL THE FAWNING
OVER OBAMA.
THE  --
>>CAN SOMEONE TELL ME WHAT
HAPPENED TO NAME MY GREATEST
STRENGTHS?
I GUESS IT WOULD BE MY HUMILITY.
GREATEST WEAKNESS.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT I'M A LITTLE
TOO AWESOME.
I...
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]
SO IN LOVE WITH YOU.
>> AND ALTHOUGH OBAMA LEFT THE
WHITE HOUSE, HIS CULT MEMBERS
HAVEN'T LEFT THE  COMMUNE.
>> YEP, FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA
IS WAITING.
>> OBAMA'S SAYS DEMOCRATS
SHOULD TALKING ABOUT KITCHEN
TABLE ISSUES.
>> AND HE WAS GRACIOUS AND HE'S
HELPING US RAISE SOME MONEY.
>> DO THEY HAVE NO ONE ELSE TO
TURN TO?
NO ONE?
DON'T THINK FOR A SECOND THAT
TRUMP'S ECONOMIC NATIONALISM,
HIS CONSERVATIVE MORE POPULOUS
PHILOSOPHY WON'T OUTLAST HIS
PRESIDENCY.
IT CERTAINLY WILL.
UNACCOUNTABLE TRADE DEALS, LACKS
BORDERS.
THOSE DAYS, MY FRIENDS, ARE
OVER.
SO LET THE GOOD TIMES ROLL,
UNTIL THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
BITTER BUSHEES COME UP WITH SOME